Alternative cancer treatment? Well, I would say that it starts with asking better questions,
maybe asking more questions. Certainly asking the question, why? Alternative cancer treatment
is not putting yourself in a box. It's looking at yourself as a unique individual with very
specific unique needs. Just because you have a disease, a name, a name of a cancer, a
breast cancer, does not mean that your cancer is the same as any other of the million people
with that same named disease. How is your body sustaining it? How is your body fueling
this cancer? Those are questions that you need to ask. And certainly your exposure to
environmental, chemical, biological toxins throughout your entire life has played a part
in this. Your current diet and how it's being fueled plays a part in this. Your current
stress level, your emotional and spiritual state, and your genetics play a part in how this
cancer is continuing to grow. So those are the things that need to be discovered and looked
at and addressed. So to me, alternative cancer treatment is really recognizing that each person
is worth more than just a standard boxed protocol. This is the way we do it for all our breast
cancer patients or prostate cancer patients. It's looking at each person as an individual
and addressing these questions. Even if a person is continuing to do standards of care,
more you could address these kind of questions and help your immune system and help your
body. I just think you're going to get a lot better success.